Yesterday, the Dow Jones Industrial Average
had once again a disastrous, disastrous day,
falling twelve point nine three percent in
a single trading day.
That is just under 3000 points in one day.
If we look at the worst declines in history
by points, yesterday was the worst day ever.
Now, I know I said this two weeks ago and
I said it twice last week.
It keeps happening.
And in fact, if you look at the biggest single
day point declines in history, nine of the
largest fifteen point declines in history
have come in the last few weeks.
Now, if we look at declines by percentage,
which may be more valuable in some sense.
Yesterday was the second worst stock market
decline by percentage ever at twelve point
ninety three percent.
The only time that the stock market had a
worse day than yesterday on a percentage basis
was the day known as Black Monday, October
19, 1987.
A historically bad day.
That's the only day that was a worse day than
yesterday by percentage.
And otherwise, you're looking at worse than
the 1920s Great Depression numbers, OK, not
the 2008 Great Recession.
Yesterday, stocks were down more by percentage
than during any day of the Great Depression
of the 1920s.
Think about that.
And this has now wiped out all of the gains
of the Trump stock market of the last thirty
eight months.
When Donald Trump took office, the Dow was
just a few points under twenty thousand one
hundred.
That's where we ended yesterday.
Twenty thousand one eighty eight.
We're back to where we were.
All of the gains of the Trump administration
are gone.
And unfortunately, this level of erratic stock
market performance and the declines are likely
not over.
We could have a long way to go.
Entire industries are unfortunately going
to be decimated.
So the question is, what can we do?
The Fed printing money is having minimal impact.
The usual suspects are going to get bailed
out, the airlines, the cruise ship companies
and many more.
But what about individuals but about small
businesses?
There's going to be some capital injections,
money made available through small business
association loans.
There will be some other stimulus, but there
will be businesses destroyed by this.
I don't know how the countless restaurants
that are currently relegated to takeout and
delivery only survive this.
Their landlords are going to want rent unless
rent is suspended or forgiven or made up by
the government.
Many restaurant owners are going to say, I
just have to walk away.
I have to walk away from the restaurant.
Even with rent support given by state or federal
government, states or state or federal governments.
Many restaurants are not going to survive
because they're just not going to make enough
money and enough money.
So right away, we probably need a combination
of some kind of universal basic income for
people making under X amount or businesses
whose gross revenues are under Y amount.
I don't know what those those numbers are,
but we probably need something like that.
Mitt Romney has suggested a thousand a month.
Ro Karna has a proposal that's a $6000 one
time payment for people making under 65k.
We need something like that.
Number two, we are going to need the government
to step in and say we will make or guarantee
mortgage payments, rent payments.
I mean, I'm thinking out loud here, all nonessential
travel is going to have to be stopped.
What counts as essential travel?
I don't know, but you've got to define it
somehow.
People need to stop moving around.
Red states are filled with people just partying
at beaches in close proximity.
These are idiots.
These are bad people.
Some of them maybe Donald Trump yesterday
finally saying this is not under control will
make a difference.
And it's tragic in many ways.
This is why it's crucial that we grin and
bear it now.
We stay home.
We try to turn the corner on new infections.
But it is not looking good.
The latest numbers as of an hour ago were
one hundred and eighty eight thousand official
cases worldwide.
I mean, the number is probably millions worldwide
at this point.
There are estimates that Ohio has 100000 actual
infections.
There are estimates that the country, the
U.S. has 500000 or 750000.
We just don't know.
We know the death toll currently has passed.
Seventy five hundred.
And we must get it under control.
The economy will suffer for a while.
It's this is going to be ugly.
But if we don't work together, it's only going
to be worse.
Let me know what you're doing.
What are you able to do on Twitter?
I'm on Twitter at Packman.
Follow me.
Let me know what you've got
going on.